GUS CLASS: Hello Google+
developers, and welcome to
this week's episode of Google+
Developers Live.
I'm Gus Class, a developer
programs engineer on the
Google+ team.
And today I'm going to be
showing you some best
practices for sign in.
If you were watching our episode
from last week, I had
started out by just at the top
of the charts, what you're
trying to do with sign in is
get the user to sign in.
And there's a couple of things
you can do to kind of
encourage the user to sign in
more and to increase the
likeliness that they're going
to sign in onto your site.
And when you sign in the user
onto your site, you get all
sorts of benefits like that
user is then able to
contribute to your site
in an easier way.
And you're able to get to that
user's data, which allows you
to draw the user into
your site more.
So if you look at my screen, you
can see the site as it was
rendered last week.
And so this is just a copy of
the demo from last week.
And in this copy, you can see
the Sign In button prominently
displayed on the right
of the screen.
You can see that encouragement
to get the user to
sign in on the left.
And when the user signs in, they
get this nice experience
where their profile is reflected
back to them.
And then it bounces to kind of
draw to their attention that
they're signed in.
So here's the basic
experience.
And here's the better
So let's disconnect.
So what I want to show
you today is
kind of the next step.
What happens before
the user signs in?
And if you look at this site,
I've made one change to this
site, and this change is kind of
a future-facing feature for
"Is too cute!" And what this
forward-facing feature is, is
it allows the user to do
something with their photos.
I haven't determined what it is
yet, but at some point I'm
going to add a feature that
brings in a user's photos from
their Google+ activity stream.
So what I've done is I've
created some code here that
just does the basics, and it
signs them in with Google+.
Now after the user signs
in, this icon
appears in the top right.
And that icon is indicating to
the user that you click here,
and your photos will
be accessed.
So if you look at the photos
here, you can see here's all
the photos that already exist
inside of my activity stream
on Google+.
And let's just take a quick
look at the code
for how this is done.
We've actually shown very
similar code in other GDLs.
So I don't want to spend
too much time on this.
But this is code that we see a
lot out there, because people
are doing interesting things
with a user's Google+
activities.
So at a high level,
what we do is we
construct that gapi client.
And then we perform a request
against plus activities list.
And we set the user ID to the
currently authorized user, get
their public collection, and
then we traverse that list of
elements that are returned
looking for images.
And so I just have a string
inside of my helper module,
and that contains the URLs
that at some point in the
future, I'll do something
with.
So what if, though, I want to
get as many photos as possible
from my users?
And so I want to use additional
data points.
So what I've done is
I've made another
version that is better.
And what this better version
does is it also tries to
retrieve files from a
user's Google Drive.
And in doing this, you're
able to bring in more
content for your site.
And you're able to allow the
user to get to more of their
data without having to go
through more effort.
So I'll sign in again, and you
can see that I haven't
refreshed the page yet.
But I'll sign in again, and now
you can see an additional
scope being requested.
The little element here that
says "View the files and
documents in your Google Drive"
has been added because
I've requested an additional
scope.
And now I just accept.
And now after the user signs
in, and the user clicks on
this little icon here with the
photos, you can see there's
more stuff here, most notably
the assets that I
created for this site.
So all these files on the
top here are files
from my Google Drive.
So this is great.
So now you have these
two scopes.
So you can do all sorts
of additional things
you couldn't do before.
Before going on, let's take a
look at how we added that
Drive scope.
So here is the code markup for
rendering that Sign In button.
And on the top, you just see
that data scope attribute, and
it's set to just Google
APIs auth plus login.
Now this is the Google+ scope.
And this is what is actually
implicit inside
of the Sign In button.
But I'm explicitly showing
it so that it's
easier for you to read.
And in the second case, what
we've done is we've added an
additional scope.
So when you want to use
additional Google APIs you
need to set up your console
project to have
those services enabled.
And then you need to request
both the scopes.
So these scopes inside of that
data scope field are just
space delimited.
And by doing this, we're
then requesting
both of those scopes.
And so I'm also doing that
photos list that I'm doing
from Google+ with the equivalent
from Google Drive.
And don't worry too much
about this code.
I just want to show that it's
very similar code when you're
accessing content from multiple
data sources using
the Google APIs.
So this just does a similar
query where it says Drive
files list.
And then I'm looking for
files by MIME type.
And this will just return all
the images that I have on my
Google Drive.
So we have both of
these scopes.
And when the user sees it, they
then say, oh, I'm going
to be granting this application
access to both my
Google+ account and
my Drive account.
For some users--
let's just say hypothetically--
this could be something that
would turn them away.
And you don't want that to
happen, because you want users
to sign in.
So you can do something
awesome.
You can do something amazing.
And you can actually do what
I like to call, dynamically
generating these scopes.
So let's turn it back to awesome
and reload the page.
And so now if you look at the
page, you can see this sort of
signal I'm giving the user when
they highlight over the
Sign In button.
The behavior is a little
bit different.
The button grays out when the
user highlights over it.
And now when the user clicks
the button, something
different happens.
I prompt the user, choose
what you share with us.
And I give them two options.
I say, I really want to see
your Google Drive files,
because we want to
allow you to do
something with these photos.
But if you just want to use
Google+, and you don't trust
us with your Drive files, or
you have sensitive stuff on
there, you can just
choose the other.
So when you click this, the Sign
In button then appears
inside the dialogue.
And when the user signs in,
the scopes that they've
selected appear here.
So because I selected Google
Drive, now I see "View files
and documents in your Google
Drive" as well
as the Google+ scope.
Now I'll cancel here.
We'll go back here.
And we'll render this again.
And if I were to switch which
instead to say only Google+
and I sign in, I get
just only Google+.
So let's make sure that this is
really doing what I think
it's doing, and let's look
at those photos again.
So because of the requested
scopes, I'm just now seeing my
Google+ photos.
And now if I were to disconnect
and reconnect, you
will see that all my photos from
Google+ and Google Drive
now will appear inside
of that photos area.
Now there's a couple of things
that I'm doing here, and
there's a couple of things
that are really worth
mentioning.
When you do this, you're losing
a lot of the built-in
functionality of the
Sign In button.
And you're losing it because
you're managing this other
dialogue in addition to
that Sign In button.
So when you do this, if you
choose to carefully select
these scopes and allow the user
to dynamically generate
these scopes, make sure that you
test the heck out of it.
Because there's a lot of simple
ways that you can kind
of do this and make the
experience not as good.
So let's see how I'm doing it
if I load up the code here.
The first thing that I have to
do when dynamically rendering
these scopes is to enable
explicit render.
So what explicit render means is
when the JavaScript for the
+1 button renders, which also
contains the JavaScript for
rendering the Sign In button,
instead of just rendering the
buttons immediately after the
HTML is loaded, what you'll be
doing is you'll be
programmatically rendering
that Sign In button.
And so when you programmatically
render the
Sign In button, you then can
manage that scope attribute
dynamically.
So I also want to emphasize
that incremental auth is
something that's kind of
more specific to--
you would encounter
it in Android.
And this is not that.
This is just managing the
scopes that are rendered
inside of that Sign In button
so that the user can
selectively turn on or off
some of those scopes.
So here's how you do explicit
render, the first part.
You have to set the Google API
scripts in JavaScript to
explicitly render that
Sign In button.
And so because I'm loading the
JavaScript asynchronously, at
the top of that JavaScript
client library boilerplate
code, I'm setting this global
variable gcfg to have the
attribute parsetags
set to explicit.
And then inside of my actual
application JavaScript, I can
programmatically render the
button through this API call.
And in my particular case, I'm
storing the client ID and the
auth scopes inside of
that helper module.
So this sort of simplifies
for me.
But you can pass strings here.
You can do it a number
of different ways.
And that first attribute that is
passed to that gapi sign in
render is going to be the target
container that's going
to render inside of your HTML.
So I've just got a span inside
that dialogue, and then I
target the span.
And as soon as I call render,
the Sign In button appears
inside of there.
And I'm also doing something--
so when I render those scopes
insider of that dialog again,
I'm just going to append the
Drive scope to just a base
scope that I'm using.
And when the user says Google
Drive and Google+, then that
Drive scope is appended to the
scope string, and then when
the button is rendered, you
see both the scopes.
And there's something
else that I'm doing.
Because of the way that I'm
managing the dialogue, I end
up also having to do this sort
of last bit of flair where I
have to re-show that little
interactive Sign In button by
looking for when the user
cancels the sign in dialogue.
Because I do something where I'm
hiding the button around a
lot and then re-showing it.
So I'm not going to recommend
right off the bat that you can
do this, but you can do this.
And I'm showing you just so that
you can sort of see all
of the various ways you can
really flair up your site with
personalization and a kind of a
look and feel that is unique
to what you like.
So here's the Sign In button.
Now because I haven't yet
rendered the Sign In button,
what I'm doing is I'm showing
this dialog with the Sign In
button in the background.
Now when I click Google Drive
or Google+, or only Google,
the Sign In button hides inside
of the background, and
then it renders again inside
of that dialogue.
And this is just something
that I like.
I just wanted to have this
sort of experience.
And I hooked in to the various
pieces of Google+.
So that here again you can see
that in the background I'm
hiding the Sign In button now.
And I'm listening for
this cancel event.
So when I click Cancel, there's
an error that's
returned to that on
sign in callback.
And then listening for that
error, I can then show the
Sign In button again.
I'll try to talk a little bit
more about this topic of
things you can do when you're
handling errors inside the
Sign In callback.
But it's going to saved for a
future episode of the sign in
best practices.
So this is really all I had to
show for you today in terms of
experience.
But I have a great example of
someone doing this dynamic
scoping from the real
world, Jolicloud.
And if you look at their site,
you see that sign in
experience that I simulated
before.
So here's a Sign In button.
Here's a Sign In with Google
button that's prominently
displayed on the front
of their site.
And when I click this, here
is one of these dialogs.
And you can select or deselect
the features that you want to
turn on and off.
And when you do this, you feel
like you can trust Jolicloud
with the things you
are sharing.
So I really like when
sites do this.
Because it allows me to
control upfront the
information that I'm sharing.
And it doesn't surprise me.
I don't ask myself, why is this
site asking for access to
my Google Drive?
I'm suspicious of that.
So by doing this you can create
a much more trusting
connection with the user.
And you can increase the
likeliness that users will
actually sign in to your site.
And once the users are signed
into your site, then you have
a lot of tools at your disposal
for driving up
engagement.
So that's pretty much it
for today's episode.
I have a couple of
announcements.
The first is that the code from
the last episode is now
inside of our GitHub pages.
So if you're interested in
taking a closer look or
running through the demo
yourself, the code's there.
And also this week, we launched
PhotoHunt in C#.
Sharp.
And so now if you are a Windows
developer and are
interested in taking a deeper
look at Google+ sign in
integrations, that sample
is available for you.
And that's it.
So please watch our Google+
Developer Live shows every
Tuesday at 2:30.
So thanks for tuning in and
look to see you next time.